Now that we've got the helper procedure, defining daysBetweenDates is pretty
simple. We have our while loop condition, checking of date1 is before date2.
And then, we update the year1, month1, and day1 values with the nextDay. And we
add 1 to the number of days. So, let's try a few examples. And this was the one
we worked out by hand earlier. We get 155. That's not exactly correct, but
that's pretty close. We got 156 when we tried this by hand. And given that our
nextDay assumes all months have 30 days, it's not surprising we don't get
exactly the right answer here. Let's try another example. This will be a good sanity
check that our solution's still fast enough. We've got 100 years here, and we
got 36000 days, it seems correct, right with our 12 months of 30 days are year
is 360 days long, instead of the correct length of the year. Let's try one more
example, try to guess what will happen here before I run it. I get the answer 0.
It's not really correct, right, those aren't the same day. It's a valid answer in
the sense that the statement of what daysBetweenDates should do said we could
assume the first date is not after the second date. In this case the first date
is after the second date, but it's not a very satisfactory answer. We really
don't want to get the answer 0. We could change the specification to say that if
the first date is after the second date, then, the result is 0. But that's sort
of a strange way of looking things. But what would make more sense would be either to
give a negative result for this, that's going to make our code more complicated.
We'll leave that as an exercise for you to do after this lesson. What I'm going
to advocate instead is to program defensively. If the assumptions that the
function depends on are not satisfied by the inputs, it's lot more helpful to
have raise an assertion to give a failure, rather than to continue and give a
mysterious result or behave in some other unexpected way. So, I'm going to ask
you to do that yourself in a quiz.